the jurgen experience well
it was a masterpiece and is it is that
your finest
moment in your your proudest moment you
feel like as a filmmaker
well it's one of the highlights of my
life and it it's the climax of this book
the 10 chapters here lead up to that
because
my story starts in 76 i'm in new york
i'm broke
depressed written 12 screenplays
nothing's happened
i've come close a few times nothing's
going on and
my marriage has ended my first marriage
and
looks i haven't accomplished my life the
things that matter
so at the age of 30 you kind of wake up
you say
you know what can i do my grandmother
dies i talk to her i go and talk to her
on her
death bed she's she's dead but in france
they let them
my mother was friends she said they they
they lay them out and
i was talking to her and then so i think
it's a very moving scene where
he communicates with her because she
loved him
and his own family life was quite
disturbing in many ways it was for him a
traumatic divorce between the mother his
mother and father
and he goes into uh he goes into this
what what happened in it's about a
family too it's about how a family life
can break apart you can become a child
of divorce
so uh his life kind of falls apart and
he goes out
you know and he goes to vietnam as a
teacher
and he goes joins a merchant marine
there's all kinds of things that happen
comes back to school goes back to yale
university
drops out again he writes a book writes
his first book
about his experiences i did this before
back in 1966 i was like 19 years old
didn't work out it was rejected it was
ultimately published about 1997 it's
called a child's night dream
so i was a writer from the beginning i i
think before i was a director
and uh when that was rejected i
just said [ __ ] it you know i'm too i'm
too full of myself i'm too much of a
narcissist
you know i can't write about myself so i
joined the army uh
and volunteered for combat and for
vietnam i didn't want to miss it you
know i wanted to
see it right away because for the
experience no i wanted to get to the
bottom of the barrel
though i wanted to see what what this
country was about i
you know i was i was inquisitive i was i
wanted to know
what life was about i mean i'd grown up
relatively sheltered you know
i went to uh my father made a living on
wall street he was a republican
eisenhower supporter he was in the
lieutenant colonel in world war ii where
he met my mother
so i mean he was uh a strong republican
and
all his life i grew up in that ethic
but it really it's something that when i
went to vietnam
he had never been in combat but when i
saw what i saw over there
coming from a sheltered existence
relatively
it was shattered the glass was shattered
it was just
i wasn't like i couldn't take my
father's word for it anymore
anything so i had to learn from myself
that's why
what was different from your father's
perceptions of what what it was
supported the war like many many people
did for several
years until he got older and then he
came around one day and he said you know
i think it's a
i think you're right i think it was it's
a futile thing because
uh the whole idea of the cold war
he he began to question it at the age of
uh
70 about 65. he said you know what
what difference does it make this domino
[ __ ] he said you know the russians
have a sub off long island you know they
can
they can nuke us from anywhere it
doesn't it doesn't make sense to play
this uh
zero-sum game of fighting for land
fighting for one country or another
intervening in other countries he began
to question everything
so uh and i was too so it i didn't
change uh
i know you're gonna go to later in my
life but basically i didn't change until
i
went to this trip in honduras which i
just told you about with my friend
richard boyle for salvador
in 1985 i went down there and what i saw
in central america confirmed
that we were doing it again we were
going into these countries we didn't
know what the [ __ ] they were about
we didn't and we were fighting these in
most cases the interests of most of the
people
the majority of the people they had a
revolution in in nicaragua because it
was so corrupt
major revolution in 1979 and uh
the uh we've been opposed to that new
regime ever since
so when you first when you entered into
the army when you
signed up did you did you have clarity
about this did you would you just have
this idea in your head that you needed
to find out no what it was like
no no i had no clarity i was
i wanted to get out of new york i want
to get away from my
the whole my parents were divorced my
father i want to get away from my father
i want to get away from everything i
knew i didn't
like yale university i was in the class
with george bush
you know i come from that generation of
donald trump george bush
bill clinton yeah same generation but i
don't identify with those people
because maybe they they didn't have that
sense of service at all
i did i had a sense of patriotism i
thought yeah but i think
call it i really think it was misplaced
but i felt
that i owe my country something i can't
work just for myself
[Applause]